hello everyone welcome to another google
hangout I am excited to have with me
Bart and Alan who are the founders of a
new company called helper desk and I'm
going to help them get going so Alan and
Bart welcome guys thank you do you want
to give a quick overview for everybody
watching what helper desk is yeah sure
so we help connect businesses with their
customers by allowing them to take all
their facebook messages tweets emails
etc and we put that all into one
dashboard so that gives you a full
overview of everything your customers
are saying to you and about you and then
you could take all of those messages and
customize organize and prioritize them
however you like awesome and we met
through there's a program here in
Toronto called Enterprise Toronto their
organization that tries to support
entrepreneurs in the city which is great
and these guys signed up for the
mentorship program and got connected
with me so here we are and one of the
things that I'm a big believer in is
building a business that stand for
something that means something finding
the one word that describes your
business and going all in on that and
and using as a way for people to care
about you not just what it is that
you're selling touch them on a deeper
level and so we've been going back and
forth and a few ideas have you guys
settled on anything it's funny because
today as we were walking to our starter
company meeting this morning see we were
we had support as the word and we had
connect as the word and then we were
debating on excellence as the word
because we were looking at possibly
changing our slogan because our current
slogan right now is connect with their
customers and we were looking at
possibly changing it to be excellent to
each other kind of a more culture
fitting slogan for for what we're doing
so what do you have any input on that so
you know there's no there's no right
word it's it's finding what's right for
you right so what means the most to you
and Allah
these will be kind of related and it's a
it's a deeper dive into your psychology
that you guys love support you love
connecting you love excellence it's
finding what overrides all of them it's
the most important one like if you had
to pick one that meant the most to you
we can only do one does one come to mind
I think I mean naturally since when the
industry of customer support support
just seems to be the word that pops out
but we want to be more about you know
ubiquitous support not just us
supporting customers with customers
supporting one another as well so I mean
I think I think if I were to have to
make a decision it probably would be
supported me on this is the fun of
partnerships here guys what what I want
you to encourage you guys to think about
though is think about who you are as
people besides what doesn't matter what
industry you're in like whatever
industry you go to you would be the guys
who cared about this more than anything
else so yes you're in a support industry
and so it works but are you mr. support
to your friends into your parents into
like you've always done stuff in the
community or not like it's cool there's
no judgment it's not right or wrong just
is this something that defines who you
are as individuals that then you bring
to your business or is it just a
marketing thing for the company i would
say it does because that's why this
that's why this business feels so right
for me when Bart told me about it I
really think it does kind of it gives a
good overview of who I am as a person
and so that's why I guess I do come back
to the word of support okay how about
you burnt ball on the other hand i
really like excellence just because it
kind of embodies support and also
embodies everything that we do like we
try to be excellent not only to each
other but everybody that we know it's
come part of our core business model
that's kind of up for debate whether we
go with support or excellence and
honestly this is this is an interesting
challenge between partners because
you have related but different words yep
like Bart is all about excellence and
Allen is all about support and so you
guys have been friends for how long
lifelong our dad went to high school
together so we pretty much grew up
together and what what ties you guys
together like what's the common value
that you guys both share that makes your
friendship work or just swear were very
similar people we're basically like
brothers from one other mother I guess
you could say we think alike we have the
same kind of behaviour I mean anytime
you ask somebody about an opinion we
have a very similar opinion about any
sort of subject that we talked about
okay how about you own I agree so when
we met um you know Allen was the heart
Bart was the head islands of support it
kind of makes sense like Allen's the
support wants to connect with people
Bart's mr. excellence and so there's
something that unites you guys one cor
kind of value and maybe a way to think
of it is somebody who is new coming onto
the team and maybe it's not support or
excellence something else somebody new
coming onto the team they can't be like
what like what's the opposite who's like
the worst person you can imagine having
on your team their way they behave or
something they believe in yeah we don't
want any mean-spirited people or anyone
who's hurtful or uncaring to either you
know to everything to do with our
business so to our customers to everyone
in our company to everyone we interact
with that's probably the worst type of
person we want to stay away from okay
mean what do you think mark well I mean
considering we're kind of in a support
industry can't really employed mean
people we have to employ people that are
that basically value our company values
they need to be supportive they need to
be excellent to not only our customers
but also everybody around them they
don't want somebody that just puts on
her show when they're in the office we
kind of want them to know when they go
out when they go home after work kind of
continue being this their excellence to
everybody that need me I want you to
think about it outside the context of
your business like the people who you've
met in your life who you can't stand are
like this rude rude okay well all you
got rude and you got you got mean which
are close so what would the opposite of
that be caring compassionate nice that's
cool what are you guys nice guys nice
guy feel like I think we are you're
pretty nice guys so like that maybe
you're closer on what the opposite is
instead of what the actual one is so
that that maybe that might be it like
going in on the nice guys we're nice
we're compassionate we're caring I guess
that all ties into being supportive as
well though right but it also ties in to
be excellent it does it was right like
these are all related and so what I what
I always encourage people that I work
with to do is have one main one and then
split it up until three different ones
to you had your own definition to the
word that you're standing for so if it's
if it's nice then what does that mean
like we are nice by doing this we r nice
by doing this we're doing we're nice by
doing that or if it's compassionate or
excellent then you add your own
definition there's always a common
definition what most people would think
but then you also add your own to make
it special you need to what you guys are
all about
what what is that is that closer does
that get us closer are we still feeling
like the other ones are better um I
think I think we're pretty much split on
on our two words here we have to have
like a common identity here for the
business or at least for that like the
public facing but it's also important on
the back end to like how if somebody who
comes into a business for support
because they love support they love
supporting people that resonates
differently compared to a message of
excellence because you could be you
could be excellent and not care what
other people not give support and you
can be really supportive and also then
suck it following through on things and
not be excellent um but I honestly think
like that I think the middle ground is
going to be something in between like
the thing that combines you is the rude
mean the negative of that of nice
compassionate caring but think about
what it is you guys have in common
that's made you friends for so long and
like stood up for each other and one
it's sort of business together there's I
think there's something else in between
that that's part of it like that'll
still be supported they'll still be
excellent with something stronger that
finds your friendship that if you get
tap into that would be super powerful to
have as your work going forward so maybe
some little extra homework for you guys
there vogel I'm gonna make boy next time
yeah so tell me about your progress
where you want i saw the website is out
but still like coming soon kind of stuff
where you guys at well we're right in
the middle of rebranding we've had our
designer basically all the designs that
were working on implementing them the
website that you actually see is kind of
an older version prior to the rear end
so that's all going to change in the
next couple weeks and then hopefully
we're hoping to get all those this brand
new stuff done and out of the way and
hopefully large around mid-september
okay coming soon a month yeah something
like that hopefully
we have the small business conference
their enterprise strata will be going to
in October so we're hoping out about a
month of actual wide usage before that
so anything iron out any bugs and things
like that okay ah the interesting thing
about branding is you can't really make
a great decision until you understand
what it is that your brand is your the
articulation of what you staying for
right so you know I come to your site
now and I see this man with a mustache
in a you know bow tie and I don't like I
stained or not but everything from your
colors to your logo to the design will
will come from you guys figuring out
what it is that you stayin for the
message that you want to have right like
if it's if it's if it's support and like
or if it's compassion or caring I'm
probably not going to go with a black
website thank you guys not now well
right it was excellent and maybe right
block could be excellence so like that's
a super important conversation if you
guys to figure out before you then jump
into the branding and designs and other
words it creates an inconsistent message
right and then branding is always
something that were continually work on
help they go ever really be completely
finished yeah but as a service it never
is man my websites always worked on
everybody website is always being worked
on okay um and so you've had people
trying it out and using it right its
installed on some people's websites um
no not quite we're still reaching the
end of development I've been kind of
using it personally just to test it out
seems to be working pretty well it's
catching all my messages and tweets and
facebook messages so hopefully it'll
work very well for the people too okay
and and then the September launch is
going to be the beta they put people on
to test it out right okay and you have
people lined up interested in testing it
out yep we have quite a few contacts
through enterprise Toronto and some of
the other seminars that we've been to we
have people that want
to some other people that are really
interested in using this as well so
mission is the lawn chair of the door
will be able to contact those people and
see what they think okay and what's the
message that your are you talking them
yet or you just you just have a list of
contacts um it's a little bit of both it
really depends on who the contact is
there have been some people that we
talked to that we've actually devil the
power to it they really loved it there
are other people that we know that
aren't really going to be interested in
seeing it until they can actually get
their hands on their use it okay and
what's the message are you how are you
pitching it lots of talents well I mean
it again it really depends on the person
that were that we're trying to target I
mean with the starter company
participants everyone in that program I
get their attention with with my
marketing presentations and I'm also
planning on doing a customer support
presentation as well so it's it's it's
mostly an educational approach to kind
of teach them and to let them know that
we have their backs in case they need us
and you know to provide this software as
well and it is free for one user to get
started with and you could accomplish a
lot with that free package as well so
everyone we've mentioned it to is
totally on board for for trying it out
once we're ready and the market is still
entrepreneurs your customers yes okay
cool so I mean you're making progress in
finding your your one word and your
branding you're in program development
getting everything ready for small
launch next month what's what's the most
i can help you with right now to help
your your business move along oh um I
think I mean just having these talks
like right now and asking us all these
all these questions just you know
obviously we're going to we're going to
finish this hangout and you know
brainstorm together we'll find our word
and try and figure out where we're at so
I think you can go having these hangouts
is great too and I mean I remember when
I told you that we were having trouble
getting our YouTube handle because
someone already owned it from another
country and you told me to just you know
find a translator go get them it was
just kind of hot you know obvious things
that we should have thought of and done
anyways but we went ahead and did that
unfortunately there was no luck with
that but we'll figure something out with
but yeah just having these conversations
is just really helpful for us to have
someone already kind of done it all
before did just kind of rattle of ends a
little bit cool so I mean Bart is away
working on the code and pounding it out
making sure it happens have you set a
milestone for how many people you want
to beta test this thing with in
September um we don't have a hard number
we've had a few numbers that we put into
our business plan that's really more for
after the data and when we actually
fully launched a paid product I have an
idea of how many people I want to use
the part obviously it can't be too many
because you know you don't want to
launch and then how that crash something
like that but anywhere between I think
10 20 people actually using the Fargo be
fantastic do you have your plenty people
from different either technology if
you're installing different kinds of
servers or different sized audiences or
different level of users like you gotta
you gotta stress test your code make
sure that it works right so you kind of
laid that out the different kinds of
customers you need or you're still
working on I think we're still working
to that list okay because when you have
that list then Alan man it's on you to
go and get those guys right and how many
of them do you have if you want that 10
to 20 how many you say I'm ready how
many of them are ready to go right now I
think I think we'd have the 10 to 20
ready to go
okay so we're just waiting on Bart we
gotta get that coat out part development
takes time now I agree I know ok so Alan
what are you doing well working for Bart
what are you doing again i mean i've
been i've been reading some interesting
books to get my presentational skills on
i'm working on a customer support
presentation and just trying to get that
that whole educational approach up to
get a really meaningful talk that i can
deliver to people you know in a
15-minute presentation we're actually in
the process of as soon as we finish this
talk we're going to send over an
application to Ryerson DMZ department
which is basically like an incubator
here so we already have a few
connections in the DMZ so we're going to
get off there and I talked to some
people who are pretty high up in in that
program and they said they would love to
have me as a speaker there to talk to
businesses and you know educate them
about marketing and about customer
support so I think that's a good
opportunity there so yeah just
networking as much as I can with with
businesses who are working on their own
projects and really getting involved
doing kind of helping people out even
when you know they ask for free
marketing advice or whatever sometimes I
just buckle down in and head go the
extra mile to kind of brainstorm
something that you know maybe sparks
some sort of an idea that just kind of
lets them know that we really do have
the box not just because we want them to
use our software book because we
actually care about the fact that we're
all in this together when all
entrepreneurs we're all trying to
achieve our dreams and you know we want
to have each other's backs when we do
like so you guys looking at the DMZ to
be in the incubator or just to make a
presentation or might actually be good
to be in it yes cool cool um I'd imagine
you need to be to really stress test it
you need to have websites that are
popular right that have a lot of
feedback come in and see if it's working
and getting feedback from like you may
put it on a star
website that's not getting any views and
has no questions is that going to solve
you know the ability to see if it's
working or not you need you have a set
like we need websites that are of this
size for this many requests per month to
see if it's worth it no we're not really
going after size at the moment the
architecture behind the actual software
should support quite a few users before
we need to start adding additional
servers or making code changes right now
we're just focusing on making sure that
everything actually works properly so
even a small sample size would verify
that okay and is there is not any risk
for the entrepreneurs of installing this
like what's the worst-case scenario
that's going to happen for them I
wouldn't really say there's much risk
simply because everything although all
the communications that they have are
still there after the fact although
facebook messages are on facebook all
their tweets on Twitter are still on
Twitter all their emails are still in
their inbox we just kind of take a copy
of that and throw it in the software and
so they can still go to the original
source of you at all okay ah Alan I
would love to see a video presentation
of what you're going to be showing these
guys sure absolutely you're already out
pitching it right i mean you're pitching
it face to face are using the power
corner what are you doing this oh I'm
not I'm not I'm crafting it currently
sorry yeah I could you get the 10 to 20
people that's just do the enterprise
Toronto connections yes oh no sorry I
thought you meant you wanted you were
asking if I had that customer support
video presentation ready to do this and
that's that's what I'm crafting just the
regular pitches yeah we're we're pretty
much talking to everyone who's willing
to listen to what we're about so what's
the difference in the pitch between your
regular pitch in the customer support
one the customer support one's not about
us very much it's not a pitch for our
business I mean if anything it's a soft
sell but it's not like a hard
promotional pitch for help or desk it's
more of the importance of customer
service in
in a business okay okay so homework you
guys going to come together to figure
out but what are we staying for as a
business and I really think there's
something there with taking a negative
of that rude mean people flipping it if
it's nice or warm or caring or
compassion or whatever and again like I
really encourage you to step outside the
business and just think of you guys as
people why your friends what's the one
word that connects you guys as friends
isn't sure you have other friends too
that you may not you know Alan we think
one of Bart's friends is a total
douchebag and whatever but he gets along
with him but there's something that like
connects you guys and that's we have to
figure out and that's what you want all
your new people coming on to be like as
well and your customers to be life and
the media understands that um Bart's
gonna get the code done right yep asal
annoying and Alan's going to keep
talking to people and make a video
presentation to look at and understand
what you're all about yep yeah cool uh
so some questions coming in Orion Dark
Knight says I'm a person has a low
breaking point and it just drains his
motivation so how do you guys deal with
your motivation like you just break you
stay motivated same whatever it is an
entrepreneur is a hard thing to do
especially at the start up before you're
making any money so how do you guys keep
going I like I like exploring you know
various forums in my industry i like
looking for good books to kind of get
inspiration from and there's always such
a more when you find a certain bit of
information it's it's just it's very
refreshing to me and then you just kind
of approach the project from a whole new
light and just dive in right again does
being in a partnership help you guys
stay motivated one guys down absolutely
yeah we run things by each other and
bounce things off each other all the
time and yeah I definitely think that
helps the one thing that really helped
me when I was getting started was
modeling success so I looked at
successful entrepreneur
is and I was in a software business like
you guys I looked at Bill Gates and
Microsoft and how we got started how
like not how he makes the next million
dollars now but like 0 to 1 how did he
do that that's what I wanted to do and
with it for him with some partnerships
but by reading those stories I just
start my day with a quick like bio
there's a book called radicals and
visionaries it like at these three page
bios and entrepreneurs and that would
that would get me one give me ideas for
what to do would also keep me motivated
to kind of keep going so you got to find
what'd you find some inspiration I'm a
regular basis daily battle like you
could have one great day you have a
great meeting and then you wake up the
next day and you're starting from
scratch at least I found for me so so
design it like start a morning routine
where you're inspired and it's real
excited he was in saying it's pronounced
Orion Orion I'm butchering his name
sorry bro he's a loyal YouTube viewer um
pumpkin bricks is asking about wanting
to start a website unsure about how to
get started easy tips what did you guys
do how did you like pick your domain
name and get your first template up and
how did you get started there Oh domain
name was a was a fun process because
that took a while if we had dreams I
think I I strapped down for a good two
to three hours with a thesaurus and a
domain and I just started throwing
things out and just you know eventually
we found help her desk and it was it was
for sale but I told all right like this
is the one we have to get this one I
don't think we're ever going to find a
better name I say it's a pretty cool
lane when it's short not that many
syllables I was surprised it was
available I wasn't available so you get
to buy from somebody else yeah cool ah
my my my website off my name I not to at
the start I did it because it was just a
personal website because I had sold my
software company and I was off traveling
because people asked me to speak in
different country
reason it was just like here's where
Evan speaking and then later as it
became like this entrepreneur hub I kind
of regretted it i wish that i had called
it small business tips or something to
get like that keyword traffic coming in
but now i'm actually happy that it's the
personal brain because my business all
is a reflection of what I'm what I'm
interested in doing and one of the
reasons why people will buy from
entrepreneurs is the personal story
right so like you guys telling your
story will be really important either
either Allen was just being like the
he's the face the heart guy or both of
you like explaining why it's important
for you why you started this what it
means for you I know Alan when we met at
the whole foods cafe you're going on
about helping entrepreneurs and why you
love us so much and right like getting
that out makes me feel a lot more
connected to you and more likely to want
to buy from you and be interested in
download and give it a try for that one
user then all the other because you're
in a competitive market there's tons of
other guys doing the same thing the
books Paul Ryan was asking what the book
was it's called radicals and visionaries
it's not available anymore uh it's out
of print and it sells for like a
thousand dollars or something now um
though yeah I kind of said I recommend
it because I love it still in my
bookshelf but you can't buy it anymore
do you guys have favorite books
recommendations for the people watching
entrepreneurs getting started I mean now
I just finished a book called talk like
Ted yeah well it's about how to speak
and how TED talks are so successful so
they're it pretty much gathered a bunch
of common tips and similarities from all
these really popular TED talks and I
think that's invaluable for any sales
and marketing person who wants to go out
or anyone who is planning on doing any
sort of a talk or conference or what not
really getting you a lot of tips and
like you were saying it's really about
that personal story people want to
really be able to connect with you on an
emotional level and not just feel like
they're being pitched at how about you
Bart favorite book reason
um I'd love to say I'm a favorite book
but I'm so busy I actually don't have
time to read too much right now my kind
of got started in a book about one of
our competitors recently but only got a
few chapters into it so far I should not
surprised I even have a bit of a tan
honestly what do you consume do you
watch a TV show do you subscribe to
youtube channel like woody where do you
get ideas and inspiration from um I do a
lot of reading of tech blogs I see other
companies kind of doing similar business
models as we do and it just it kind of
gets me excited to start my own business
to come do that myself like I really
kind of lean towards the tech side of
things so just seeing how these websites
work and how they're developed and other
code it just gets me excited that's
really where I get most of my
inspiration from cool so like TechCrunch
tech knives oh yeah for sure oh um oh
this is a good one for you guys gallardo
five million how would where'd you find
a partner that has the same mindset as
you it's been hard finding someone I can
vibe with honestly I mean we just got
lucky we grew up together right we never
knew that as kids we were going to be
business partners right so I think with
us it's uh it came down to luck but in
like the program were in for example
it's just you're around all these
like-minded people who know people who
are similar to that so I'd say
definitely get involved in some sort of
an entrepreneurial program or even
forums online and just try and connect
with people there and you might find
that there's someone that you talk more
and more often with because they really
resonate what you believe yeah I think
it's easy a lot of monitors make the
mistake of bringing on a partner or even
bringing on an employee so we're like
when you guys are growing of they have
all the skills that we need so let's
hire them while ignoring like the
cultural fit which is super important
Bob Selena and in a business partnership
like you you will spend more time with
your business partner than you will
with your wife or your girlfriend and so
it's gotta be somebody that you can
really really get along with and so yeah
I mean super super important and and
yeah I mean you guys are lucky being
born into it almost your your parents
getting along but otherwise yeah i mean
i like gallons point it's hanging out
with people uh I would start getting
involved in communities where you're
passionate and just telling your story
and what you're all about what you're
looking for and and you'll run in what
you're running the people you'll explore
you don't find it by sitting at home all
right you find it by getting out and
connecting with people and I found great
people in even the salsa community I'm a
salsa dancer and DJ and investor and
just by doing what I'm excited about I
end up meeting people to have a
connection somehow I can use them in my
business as well so explore what you
like to do and you'll end up meeting
some good people do you have any tips on
how to practice being more personal and
different maybe leverage something from
your book there Alan uh tips for
personal in a presentation sense i'm
gonna masoom yeah so he's an actor he
wants to he's an actor and wants to
practice being more personal and
different oh I feel like I should be
acting asking the actor for advice not
the other way around I found I mean if
in a sense of doing videos and whatnot I
just record myself and then I play it
back and I critique and see you know am
I umming and I too much or am i
stuttering or am I not getting my point
across and that just gives me a good
idea of where I'm at and then do I
believe myself to you know is it
personal because maybe coming out of my
mouth it feels personal but hearing it
back maybe I missing things that that
should be there that I should be
included for me was tapping into my
passion more I feel like if you go back
to my youtube channel the content that I
talked about was the same it's still
good content just a delivery has gotten
way way way better and that's one
through practice
but also injecting more passion into
what I'm talking about and feeling it
more one of the things that I try to
remember when I'm making a video or
doing a presentation is some of the
river is watching is about to make a
really important decision in their life
and this video or this presentation is
the last thing they're going to see
before they make that decision and so I
have to have an impact so like raising
the stakes make it more important is
important whether you're an actor
whether you're an entrepreneur right
like your product your service could
make the difference between a business
going out of business and not right it
has that ability that potential and so
approaching a situation knowing that you
can help them and knowing that we could
make a meaningful impact on your company
it comes out like it comes out and how
you speak it comes out in your pitch
much more than just here are the 10
things that we do uh how important is an
NDA dread doc if you guys sign NDA's
with anybody no um I start about sunny
in India with our designer or people
that I think that will depart to but
honestly everything I've heard about
it's just kind of pointless not really a
forcible yeah you got to have you gonna
I mean the nda's you gotta you gotta one
prove that they shared the knowledge
somehow and then to be willing to sue
them if anything happened um I don't
sign NDA's I get too many ideas from
people and never sign NDA's um so I
don't know it's a it's a you can use it
people sign it great but you have to be
willing to enforce it that's the biggest
thing sumeet how do you get up again and
again and again to face failure well we
haven't failed yet so if we do let you
know it's it does come down to the whole
passion thing right just like wanting to
be exactly where we are right now and
realizing that there are hurdles and
there are tough spots and there's
going to be hard days and there's going
to be really bad days but with that
comes the good it did my audio just cut
out no no we got you okay cuz my
computers at one percent right now and I
don't have a charger so I'm luckily Bart
entirely 10 feet away so I might have to
switch computers in the second yeah well
switch it up um I think people have an
interesting view on failure I don't see
failures a bad thing I think if you're
not failing than you are not doing
anything even close to big if you're
playing in a world where there's no
failure then you're playing it so safe
that your life is super boring and
you're never going to do anything great
failure is normal failure is part of the
path to success I feel all the time I
don't know I probably fail the 10 things
today already the key is just not to
make the failure so huge so astronomical
and so a lot of entrepreneurs go through
that you get one failure and then you're
you're like I'm never gonna make it this
isn't gonna work out and shut down where
look at them they're together yeah yeah
we are you guys roommates too no not yet
probably will be one some business
starts so whose place a you are now fine
all right cool there you go he literally
was like just right next to you but yeah
so like failures is a part of the
journey don't don't fear failure you
will fail don't don't take it personally
just it's only failure if you don't move
forward from it it's only feel if you
didn't learn and then take forward
progress if you're doing anything even
remotely risk changing then you're gonna
have some failure along the way I know
we're kind of bumping up against the
clock so maybe one last question uh this
is from Lee Barrett I'm passionate about
my projects but I know that progress
would have been greater if I connected
with others so I guess trying to do too
much yourself how do you guys deal with
it it's never too late to connect with
others I mean if that's how how they
feel then you know get out there and
whatever you
wish you could have done you still can
do I can't imagine there's there's a
deadline or a time period that's already
expired that prevents you from still
connecting with all those people I like
that answer so much i'm not going to add
anything to it we design there I love it
Alan Alan ends the show um cool well you
guys have some homework to do try to
hosted and for everybody to watching go
check out helper desk I know the web
sites under development is going to
start changing soon you guys have a
youtube channel you have it up yet why
it ok coming soon next time we'll plug
the youtube channel as well all right
all right thanks guys thanks everybody
for watching and we'll see you all soon
thank you thanks hey guys